in addition to black lives matter um
there's also a movement for
black trans lives matter did you talk a
little about that
yeah you know i got a lot of heat
um i did a message to america on my
um instagram and i got a lot of heat for
calling black people out
um the relationship that the
african-american community has
with the lgbtq plus community is
not good
and trans women specifically black trans
women trans women of color
are dying at the hands of cis black men
at alarming rates and what i'm saying
is it's a simple do unto other
others metaphor right
we want somebody to stop killing us
we have to make sure that we have our
house in order
period and it's a conversation
that pose presents it's an
uncomfortable conversation you know
because
trans lives are
the next on the list of dismissable
humans trans people are human beings
i'm a gay man but i'm a black man first
and until black people understand that
we're going to be in the quagmire going
round and round
you can't expect somebody else to change
until we can look at ourselves and make
that transformation within ourselves
i mean i think that's i mean that's
applicable to
all of us yes you know even in whatever
your situation is in life and whatever
you're going through and your personal
hurdles and challenges like i think
you know you can't expect others to do
that unless you're willing to do it
yourself and
really take a look in that mirror um so
i think i think that
um it's amazing that you're standing up
um for
everyone subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going